hiya my name is elizabeth i'm a medical
student and an artist living in london
and in this video i wanted to go through
the top 10 things i wish i'd known
before starting
medical school now these are only my own
personal opinion
so please bear with me but if you're
planning on going to medical school
hopefully these will serve useful to you
and if you're already a medical student
or a doctor and you've felt
the same way please let me know i love
finding out that i'm not the only person
in the world who
experiences things a certain way and yes
those are my two goals here
hopefully i can get some of it
accomplished let's get straight into it
the first thing i wish i'd known is that
medical school is not as hard as they
say
now this is a very controversial one
because i think that stereotype of the
overworked underslept struggling to
understand
medical student is so so prevalent and
strong
but i did not find that this was
necessarily the case for me i wish i'd
known
that the things that we need to
understand in medicine are actually
not that difficult the last time i
struggled to understand something was
probably in high school with further
maths and advanced physics but it was
definitely never in
university the difficulty only lies in
the workload but even that
is not as bad as it seems or as
exaggerated as
people make it out to be i wish i could
have told myself that you'll be
absolutely fine it is not that
terrifying or difficult
and yeah i think this would have calmed
me down a lot
the next thing i wish i'd known is how
much free time i would have in
medical school i thought that i was
signing off my life for five to six
years
and i would be unable to do anything
else this was absolutely
not the case i've been working full-time
while i've been in medical school
alongside it i've also been involved in
so many different projects when i
started first year
i felt a bit guilty with all of my free
time
and i wish i would have known beforehand
that actually
you the busiest time of your life is
probably not going to be in medical
school the next thing i wish i'd
appreciated is
how long medical school is now
when it comes to this a lot of people
have told me oh i could never study
something that lasts five years or six
years and i thought well you know that's
not a big deal
and it definitely isn't and it's not the
length of medical school
in itself that i want to talk about but
it's rather
what doing a single thing for five years
will do to
you so the way that i would like to
describe this is for example
if we think of ourselves today and we
think of ourselves five years ago
it's very very likely that those two
people are extremely
different and this has definitely been
the case for me
in my second year of medical school i
found that all the reasons
for which i've wanted to do medicine
have disappeared
or changed or i fully disagree with them
so i think that if you do anything over
five years or even if you do nothing
over five years
you will definitely change a lot and you
might find
that the person that you become does not
feel the same way about your university
or about your workload or about what
they want to do for the rest of their
lives
so this was something that i really
hadn't considered i started medicine
thinking i would always have the same
view on life and the same desires and
needs and that definitely changed so
i think having a bit more of an open
mind when i started
is something i wish i'd done the next
thing which ties onto this
is that i wish i'd believe people when
they told me that it's very unlikely
that i'm going to want to do the
specialty
that i got into medicine wanting i
wanted to be a surgeon for the longest
time and when i started medicine a lot
of people would tell me oh you just wait
you're going to change your mind
and to me that was very offensive
because i thought that that meant
them saying that i'm not smart enough to
be a surgeon i'm not hardworking enough
to be a surgeon or just because i
am a female that i would want to have
children and
kind of not want to work out of hours or
have a career that takes so much time
out of my life
and for all of these reasons i stuck
very firmly to it and got offended
every time someone would tell me that
now i wish i could have seen
beyond that emotional response into
realizing
that things change and the things that
you appreciate or like about medicine
are also likely to change
and therefore your specialty might also
not be the same
now having said that i know that there
are people who had you know
their mind set to be a pediatrician at
the age of three and still are very very
happily during that career at the age of
70
but for the most of us we change a lot
and the things that we like to change a
lot and we might grow particularly
attached to a specialty just because we
have these amazing consultants that make
it seem as though it is the best thing
in the world
or we might change our mind again and
again and all of these things are
absolutely normal i think that being not
too
attached to one specialty when you start
to medical school is a good
idea because then if you do change your
mind you won't go through an identity
crisis like i did
thinking that oh my god what do i do now
when i started questioning whether
surgery was
right for me by the way it still remains
one of my favorite medical specialties
it's just that i'm not sure that that is
the career that i want for the rest of
my life
the next thing i wish i'd known and i
think that this is the most important to
me
is that the things that people tell you
are going to be difficult in medicine
are not actually the most difficult
thing in medicine
so i thought that seeing a dead body or
dissecting a dead body or being in
surgery
or having to stress over exams or having
such a huge workload was going to make
medicine very very challenging for me
the reality was very very different i
absolutely
loved dissection i got used to the smell
of quarterization
after my first surgery and i've never
stressed the slightest over
exams that's not to say that medicine
has been easy it was just things that i
did not expect to encounter
things that stayed with me the most and
got the most under my skin
and kept me up for weeks where certain
encounters with patients were in
i felt as though we weren't really
making a difference seeing patients who
are being abused for example but who
refuse to report that abuse
while you treat their asthma is
something that has kept me up or cases
in psychiatry where you do feel a huge
sense of helplessness
and hopelessness are the things that i
find the most challenging about medicine
and i was not prepared for this at all
the next thing i wish i'd known is how
expensive medical school can be
and i'm definitely biased here because i
live in london
but it's insane rent on its own
paying for food and the thing about
london is that hospitals are so
scattered
so for example in the same day i need to
go to one part of london for my lectures
another part of london for training
another part of london to
process data for the study another part
of london to work
and then go home which is obviously not
close to any of these
every day takes a lot of money and time
and on top of that you do need to pay
for all of the extra training or
all the extra diplomas you want to do
for example any sort of extra thing you
want to do
i had a poster up at a conference last
year going to that conference and
putting it up on its own
cost about 400 pounds so i did
definitely not appreciate how even
wanting to do
extra things that would be good for
medical school would cost me
so much money i'm working on the side at
minimum wage is a very difficult way to
make up for this
so i definitely did not appreciate the
financial difficulties
that i would be facing at times in
medical school the next thing i wish i'd
known
is that you still need to do things that
you don't
want to do a lot of you may be a lot
more mature than i was in high school
but i remember passionately feeling in
plant biology which i hated that i
cannot wait to go to university to study
only the thing that i care about which
is the human body and be done
with all these topics that i could not
care about less
this is not necessarily the case there
will always be things that you do not
find as interesting
in my case that is microbiology for
example but also
things like studies i absolutely hate
sitting in front of a computer and
processing numbers for hours and hours
and weeks and weeks
i find it incredibly boring but this is
something that i have to do
as a medical student and i will have to
do as a doctor in the future too so
so i think being a bit calmer and not as
dramatic and
lowering my expectations for now i only
get to do what i want once i go into
medical school
would have been a bit more realistic in
my case the next thing
that i wasn't ready for was how people
were going to treat me once i started
saying i'm
a medical student if any of you have
experienced this kind of
look or the embodiment of the stereotype
of oh
you must be so serious and you must be
so hard working
and oh you must have no free time you
must be so sleep deprived
and i mean the stereotypes can go both
ways i felt that i was not ready to be
thrown in
to this medical stereotype so soon and
the next thing i wish i'd known
is that medical school although it's
five years
is not actually like any other
university degree
if you're thinking you're going to get
that university experience
it's probably not going to happen in
medicine and i wish i'd known this
i started out so slow paced thinking oh
i've got five to six years ahead of me
i don't need to engage as much in
university activities but
at king's for example we only have one
year of pre-clinical medicine
and after that you're almost never in
university at all
your projects are for yourself to do on
your own your learning is
is almost only with practice in hospital
and you're not feeling that university
experience
so if you think that oh you're going to
get six years of what others get for
three years
that may not necessarily be the case if
i've known this i would have definitely
appreciated my first year
a bit more and the last thing i wish i'd
known
is something that would have given me so
much hope and that is just how
incredible people are in medicine so
many medical professionals and medical
students and people that i get to spend
time with are absolutely mind-blowingly
inspiring they're passionate about what
i'm passionate in but a lot of them are
hundreds of times better than i am at it
and i find this
so so so inspiring there's so many
opportunities to learn
and to feel good when you see people
excelling at what they do
and definitely this is something that i
am endlessly grateful for
so yes those were 10 of the many many
realizations that i've had in medical
school
hopefully if you're planning to be a
medical student any one of these will
help you
or apologies if they do shatter any of
your expectations
so yeah as always if you made it so far
thank you so so much for spending this
time with me i hope you have
a wonderful rest of your day be kind
yourself and others and don't believe
everything you think
thanks bye